Levi's a brand we all know the iconic
jeans maker they've survived through
Wars depressions they've survived for a
hundred and sixty years but it could be
yoga pants yes yoga pants that finally
does the company and that is the cover
story of the latest issue of Bloomberg
Businessweek you can find it online
today on newsstands tomorrow
Bloomberg's Tim Higgins wrote the story
and he joins me now from San Francisco
so Tim just how much trouble is Levi's
in well
Levi's is doing great in the men's
market has 25% of it globally for jeans
but women's they've only got 5% globally
and in the past year in the u.s. Jean
sales for women has decreased by 8% and
NPD tells us that it's on a one-to-one
basis now there's many jeans there's
being sold as yoga pants it's really
kicking their butts in some ways and so
they really set out to kind of create a
gene that would be more appealing to
women but still be still be jeans still
be denim so what they come up with I
know you spoke to the director of
technical innovation I didn't realize
that denim companies have directors of
technical innovation but the story is
very cool you actually went into the
labs what are they doing to compete with
Lululemon yeah the company that created
jeans that created the modern jeans all
those years ago has opened a lab two
years ago in San Francisco in downtown
San Francisco just four blocks from
their corporate headquarters and they've
got this these all these guys all these
men and women working on the future of
denim and a future of jeans and they
they got into the the fabric level
breaking down what made something
comfortable what made something more
resilient if they were to insert it with
the denim in the in these in these
products they talked about ways to use
lasers to essentially contour the fabric
and a way to make it look more appealing
on a woman they they've used various
other techniques to just make this new
material look and feel like traditional
denim but be softer and more stretchy
like more popular pants so are these
still gonna look like jeans or they look
like skinny
jeans are they gonna look like jeggings
the hybrid denim legging right the
jeggings would be the enemy in this
situation they do not want to create
something that doesn't look authentic to
the Levi's brand and so these jeans look
like jeans in fact you know holding them
up sometimes I couldn't tell which was
the new one in which was the old one it
was touching them that you was really
the key of softer my in fact I took a
young woman to try some jeans on as a
secret shopper and she was blown away by
it really shocked that how comfortable
and easy to try on they were it you know
normally it's really hard to find her
the best hit fit of jeans and she put
one right off the shelf and it fit
immediately it is nearly impossible to
find the perfect pair of jeans perhaps
that's why some people like jeggings
because they fit no matter what size you
are so to be clear Tim the problem is
not that people are buying is the
problem that people are buying less and
less jeans to wear or that they are
buying less Levi's jeans
it's jeans in general really what's
going on is that yoga pants have been
you kind of become the thing that you'd
wear on the weekends you can not just to
yoga but to the farmers market to all
the leisure activities that you probably
in the past would've wore jeans too and
so the idea here is to kind of get back
into that category jeans are still
popular for work they're still popular
for going out in the evenings but it's
getting back to the kind of the thing
you wear whenever you kind of need to
wear something that's not work clothes
is the trick Jim so Levi's now has this
sort of cool hip youngish CEO what's his
strategy here though it's definitely
that he's putting more resources into
into doing women's jeans in the past
they they focused heavily on menswear
they still do very well he's he's a
couple of several years into a
turnaround plan it was going pretty well
he's had two consecutive years of
revenue growth and operating profit and
this year if he's successful in part
because of the women's jeans he might
have the third year of revenue adjusted
revenue growth and adjusted profit
growth would be the first time in 20
years the company has done that yeah I
will leave it there thank you so much
looking forward to reading your cover
story distressed denim it is the
bloomberg businessweek cover story out
on newsstands and online